[Musique]
alors est ce que on parlait de nabila
est ce que vous l'art verrier dans tp
est ce que ça vous ferez perella belong
dans la sarre et passager accepte un
camion lui pose la question et on
parlera aussi du dic parce qu'elle m'a
fait une petite dédicace à leur goût
jean-michel apparemment vous l'aimé
beaucoup
oui donc j'aime beaucoup évidemment d'un
point de vue amicales oui je serais
content d'un point de vue esthétique wii
est actuellement non ce que je n'ai rien
fait pour les matches seront très maline
donc elle dit toujours ce qu'elle ce qui
va faire un peu le buzz mais c'est pas
vraiment ce qu'elle pense donc je trouve
c'est faux donc on va faire le tour du
photo mc vous le trouver mais c'est j'ai
l'impression de voir matthieu delormeau
la sepa jean-michel n'a évidemment le
meilleur je vous souhaite bien et c'est
pour ça que j'ai pas ce que je faisais
des genoux souhaite voir faire d'autres
choses que toujours un moshav htc desire
doute chose qu'être ainsi que je suis
vieux
moi je suis heureux j'ai pas ton âge ma
chérie ma chance ici la retraite mois à
la boulimie là on aime comme vous êtes
vrai j'aime le côté alors attendez là
vous allez entendre quelqu'un parler
pour ne rien dire
20h36 voilà donc mais vous allez voir à
la fin il chérit qu'est ce qu'il a dit
lui vous êtes drôle vous avez des propos
concis et vous savez rebondir sur toutes
les situations avec humour j'aime
beaucoup ce que vous faites
mais alors elle voudrait pour n'est pas
la question de la polémique aux immigrés
dont j'ai loupé cette raison que
j'aimerais le voit à la voir peut-être
revenir de temps en temps ça leur dire
que le problème c'est qu'à la fin de sa
réponse tu te seras plus là quasiment
thomas attention alors un jour alors
viens méfiez-vous 2000 et sur tous les
dossiers
mais j'aime beaucoup il est confirmé sur
twitter
sk je suis sur twitter
denis auguin se gâtent quand il suit
quelqu'un sur [ __ ] on dirait qu'ils le
suivent vraiment dans la rue
[Applaudissements]
au ghana avec son iphone os si je suis
le gars qui dormait nabila sur twitter
le sympathique vous demandez un recueil
ajustements merci j'ai déjà un petit peu
de mémoire au corps oui gilbert des oui
moi vous me manquez nabila je trouve que
ce serait bien que vous reveniez j'ai
envie que vous soyez là vous aviez des
interventions l'une est revenue une
femme vous avez des fulgurances
quand est-ce que vous revenez nous voir
avec vous maintenant vous finissez les
phrases mais ont l'air vous vouliez dire
un truc sur le livre également bah oui
je vous intéressant yves nabila est
inclassable vous rendez hommage à cyril
en disant qu'il a été le premier à avoir
l'audace de vous prendre comme quand on
lit que ce n'est pas évident à l'époque
mais dont je trouve que ce serait très
bien de boucler la boucle et de revenir
à cette voie là le sont avec huit heures
isabelle morini ce mot alors moi je suis
entièrement pour le retour de la villa
elle le sait et contrairement à toi jean
michel je pense qu on n'est qu'au début
et qu'il ya vraiment une partie de
donald blake n'a pas été exploité c'est
juste parle pas du physique je parle des
intérêts et qui est vraiment mérite de
l'afp c'est ici que s'adapter à ça fait
sept ans que les gens dit nabil asli
elle est là depuis 2010 un habile art et
elle continue mais c'est vrai mais sans
rien et chaque année on entend voilà
c'est sécession alors femme fatale elle
dit quoi je n'assume pas trop le tiche
mais j'étais moi j'étais devant ma télé
qu'on habille la été chroniqueuse je
suis arrivé a pas très longtemps donc
j'ai pas eu la chance de faire cette
émission avec toi et je te trouvais
parfaite extrêmement fraîche extrêmement
pertinentes et je trouve que nabila et
thomas d'ailleurs ils ont eu cette
intelligence de parfaitement capté la
société la génération et ont tiré profit
très intelligemment ils ont capté la
société jolie miss it et quolibets
attention est bonne et le décalage
toujours 25 ans a fait moi comment la
violence et crise d'ado c'est là
et le sens interdit sur ma porte et a
pas droit à la foux troquet m'en fiche
d'accord je vais pas en contrôle
histoire-géo mais n'a pas des stadistes
et j'ai attendu et l'autre sont des
connaisseurs n 12 est une crise d'ado ce
qu'elle a laissé la brigade mais vous
quand même vous savez qu'à l'âge de 10
la pareille 25 ans également 6e de
personnel j'ai l'impression que ça fait
50 ans qu'on est moi j'ai l'impression
que ça fait ça fait dix ans que je suis
que je suis dans le kent mais c'est vrai
à 25 ans j'ai 30 ans on tombe ça va et
au 31 la fleur de l'âge on a beaucoup
qui sont dans la fleur de la grille mais
ils sont un petit peu fané
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on est concerné par ça donc j'ai pas
taillé sa chérie non mais nabila ne
laisse personne indifférent évidemment
comme beaucoup dans et autour de cette
table à la sa place parce que qu'on aime
ou qu'on les fesses on aime la regarde
et on aime écouter donc forcément elle
doit revenir dans tpm p non parce que ça
mon soirée c'est vrai j'ai que des bons
souvenirs avec la ville a donc
évidemment je serais heureux qu'il
revienne mais moi j'aime bien aussi par
thomas et martin aussant a dit loeb à un
des seul truc qui m'a plu c'est qu'on
découvre thomas dans la télé réalité et
je suis sûr qu'il a des choses à offrir
un point de vue et jean bien de voir
aussi une fois tout autour de la table
il sans habits là pour l'instant ils
sont toujours collés l'un à l'autre
ouais je pense qu'il peut le faire d'ohb
ou tard cette fois sûr et bien sûr et
bien vous allez le retenir ça on
retrouve tout son passé trouble et honda
du média bordel je trouve également
revenir mais si jean-michel n'est pas la
table un jour si les êtres
c'est vrai je vous ai posé la question
parce qu'on vous avez vous manqué
beaucoup enfin c'était cité l'expérience
deus et voilà c'est sûr que ça manque
alors quoi je vous dire je serais
vraiment moi je vous dis le problème
qu'hier c'est que j'engage tout le monde
sur la tête de ma mère
bon je fais l'étape de tmp on dirait que
les étapes de mariage céréales bascule
maintenant il ya la plains nombre lui il
faut pas le mettre avec lui lui non
c'est le mardi parce que le mardi la
escrime mercredi n'en ait de quoi il va
la table de l'autre parce que ya c'est
que des gens de la photo de rentrée qui
sont toujours pas passés
c'est bref le top alors monde ne passera
pas cette année c
sur les dix prochaines années en fait
les séries dramatiques
la photo de rentrer si les gens vous
allez voir sous les 10 prochaines années
d'accord donc ça peut arriver là le
royaume comme dans rue89 renvoi lattier
les gens qui vont se succéder
autour de cette table et bien sûr on
n'en sera que plus joyeux alors est ce
que vous avez envie de la ville
argovienne ou paraisse que non oui à 46%
noah 5 à 4 c'est plutôt partagés voilà
mais c'est vrai et moi moi je vous le
dit la bible
j'adorais quand vous étiez là donc vous
revenez quand vous voulez vous le savez
que je vous aime énormément et thomas
vraiment ne t'inquiète pas on sera là
pour s'occuper de nabila s'il ya un mec
avec un t-shirt oaxaca un blouson
moutarde qui a chine
je te jure que je sors à envoyer la
mayonnaise